hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com so in this video i want to
talk about
the bitcoin everybody is born on the
bitcoin i was bullied on the bitcoin i'm
seeing bullish on the bitcoin but
uh i want to show you guys what i see
what i think is going to come soon
and what level are we going to let's get
into it
[Music]
so in the video i did on this channel
one month ago i was saying
that after we have bridge so this is the
bitcoin uh since the beginning all right
uh so after we have uh broken this trend
line
that was here at ten thousand i was
bullish i didn't care about the 19500
maximum level we have here
because the market is developing in
waves not in steps all right
so it's not uh vertical levels that we
are breaching
it's sloping uh trend lines that we're
breaching and so that's why for me here
this won't wouldn't be a problem and it
wasn't all right
i was here saying guys for like the
whole week we're gonna break it we're
gonna break it we're gonna break it and
it's gonna be massive
this is what happened all right now the
bitcoin is at 33 000 guys
where do you think we might possibly be
heading
i gave you already my answer i will give
it again
i use fib extensions guys this
is the only way we have here
to predict what level are going to be
the next resistance levels because we
are in a noman's land there is
never the bitcoin has never traded in
this area
so we take the previous wave we measure
it all right
so here i'm going gonna measure to the
19500 level
all right where we had a lot of um
reactions
and i'm gonna apply this move in the
logarithmic scale of course because this
is the bitcoin guys the bitcoin is
crazy in the levels here if you're not
watching this in the logarithmic scale
wouldn't make any sense all right and
then
i'm just checking what is my next fib
ratio
fib uh extension ratio so the 1.618 guys
so this was my first level
34 000 here i was saying 35 it doesn't
really matter all right
this is not very precise this is just an
area
so we are almost there don't be
surprised if you see
some selling flows coming um this week
in the market
because you know i can't explain
exactly how this is working but this is
growth all right
growth always follows these ratios if
you look at my finger guys
the ratio between this and this is 1.6.8
and between this
and this here is 1.6.8
and even between this and this
is 1.618 guys this is
how things just grow and the market is
doing the same thing
so probably here we're going to have a
reversal all right
if we don't the next one is 55 000 but i
think this is gonna
start to get weaker maybe uh rejected
here
re-testing the 20 000 area guys
everybody thinks the bitcoin is going to
100
000 maybe but before that trust me
usually there is a retest of the last
uh resistance level that becomes support
which is
here 20 thousands so we're going to
retest it it's going to be the
kind of last chance for you guys that
have
not bought it yet to get into this
security
if you wish to i think that the nice
possible scenario is that we have
something like this all right
so we are doing something here okay
this is gonna be a consolidation level
then you're gonna
check on the shorter time frame when we
are breaking it and then
probably we are going to go lower to
re-test this and then we go higher all
right
so this would be for bitcoin a move of
35
lower which is something that happens
not every day
but quite often on the bitcoin all right
it's not going to be one move down all
right it's going to be a few times five
ten percent something like this
but yes and this is going to go together
with s p 500 i think that is going to
correct as well and the dx y that is
going to go
up so guys if your long dust
maybe it's time to take profit i don't
know do what you think is the best
but anyways stay close to shore